Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Costco food in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Here is an iconic Costco
hot dog in the UK.
Ah, yes.
The famous Costco hot dog.
In the UK, the length of
a hot dog is 8 inches.
Don't laugh.
Joe: 8 inches.
Almost exactly 8-inch dog.
It's also advertised as a
quarter-pounder hot dog.
Let's see if that's true.
So, with the bun and some onions,
the whole thing weighs 250 grams.
I want to take the sausage
out and weigh that on its own
to see if that is a quarter pounder.
Turns out that without
the bun and the toppings,
it does weigh exactly
a quarter of a pound.
That's pretty impressive.
I know it's manufactured
and mass-made by machines,
but, you know, still cool.
Oh, my God.
It's exactly 4 ounces.
Wow!
They kept it a quarter pound
after it's cooked and everything.
See?
Costco. It's not impossible.
All these people watch
this and they're like,
"Mm, it's a quarter of a
pound before you cook it."
Well, they said 4 ounces.
Whatever they're doing, after it's cooked,
it is the advertised 4 ounces.
Way to go, Costco.
In the UK, a Costco pizza
is 17 inches in diameter.
That makes the surface
area 227 square inches.
In the US, our Costco pizza should also be
18 inches in diameter.
Let's measure it!
More like 17 ½, Costco.
It's still $9.99.
That's a ridiculous deal.
You can keep that half an inch.
Our pizza today was cut into six pieces.
I'd say for a pizza of this size,
it's kind of uncommon
to see only six slices.
I would expect maybe eight
or 10, like at Domino's.
But we're going to weigh one slice
and find out how big it is.
Now let's weigh one slice.
That is a dense slice of pizza.
There's some citation needed,
but this might be the
heaviest slice of pizza
we've ever weighed on "Food Wars."
That's a big layer of cheese.
Not a ton of tomato sauce.
I would say it's maybe 70% bread.
So I don't know if you're
getting a ton of value for money
when it comes to toppings.
I quite like it.
It's got that nostalgic,
cheap-frozen-pizza quality.
The chicken bake.
I don't know what the origin of this is,
but it's a pretty good idea.
It's just, like, a giant
chicken Hot Pocket, right?
The guy holding up the
fish that he's just caught.
We've already used this
gag in a recent episode,
but we can reuse it.
I am curious.
Oh, why is this so good?
This is so good.
I will say, I love stodgy food.
So I feel like I am the target audience
for all of these foods.
The fountain drinks in
the UK come in one size,
and it's supposedly 22 fluid ounces.
Of course, we have to check it.
So, in what seems to be an increasingly
rare occurrence on "Food Wars,"
that is actually as much
drink as we were promised.
That's 22 ounces.
But the fountain drinks in
the US are 20 fluid ounces.
Look at that. It's exactly 20 ounces.
And I filled it up at the thing.
Man, Costco is razor-sharp
with the portions, right?
They're not leaving anything to chance.
Thank you, Costco.
Here are all the Costco
menu items in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here are all the Costco
menu items in the US
you won't find in the UK.
Quick disclaimer that the
menus seem to vary slightly
depending on where you
are in the UK or the US.
I got these from the Chingford location
just outside of London,
and Joe's got his from the
Burbank location in California.
We have one exclusive pizza
option in the UK from Costco,
and it's this one, the
barbecue chicken pizza.
As the name suggests, it's
a barbecue chicken pizza,
which also comes with
some green bell peppers
and some red onion.
When I see a barbecue pizza in the UK,
I usually grimace because it tends to mean
that the sauce is barbecue,
and I don't like that.
But I think here, they've
actually just kept
the same cheese and tomato base
but added the barbecue toppings on top,
which in my opinion is what
a barbecue pizza should be.
Leon does not agree.
It still feels pretty hefty.
Maybe not quite as dense or as hefty
as the cheese pizza did.
The dough seems to be not quite as thick.
Try just the chicken on its own first.
It's not bad. I'm not getting much
barbecue flavor from that.
It's more just like a
sort of grilled chicken.
Usually my biggest
complaint of barbecue pizzas
is that they're too barbecuey,
whereas this one actually
isn't very barbecuey at all.
That means that I like it.
But if you do normally like quite a strong
barbecue-sauce flavor from your pizzas,
this one might not be enough for you.
In the UK, you can also get whole pizzas
as part of a family bundle.
The bundles come with a full-size pizza,
one of these gigantic garlic breads,
two of these garlic-and-herb dips,
and also a 2-liter bottle of Pepsi Max,
half of which I have spilled
on the floor of the studio.
Twisted churro.
We got these, you guys don't.
It's not a lot of stuff. All right.
This thing, churro, cinnamon, dough.
Mm.
Next up we've got Costco's
take on a classic British dish,
cottage pie.
Now, our American viewers may
have heard of shepherd's pie.
Cottage pie is basically the same thing
in that it's a layer of
some cheese on top, usually,
some mashed potato,
but instead of the lamb-mince mixture,
cottage pie contains beef mince.
Now, this is a classic British dish,
and we do feel pretty passionately
about things like this.
So let's hope Costco have done it justice.
The strategy seems to be
sell large quantities of food
but really pack it with
the kind of cheap stuff.
So, for example, there's a small amount
of cheese on top here,
a very small amount of beef on the bottom,
and I'd say, like, 80% of
this is just mashed potato.
Let's give it a try.
It's actually quite tasty.
I don't work for Costco, I just,
I'm a truth seeker.
Again, the beef is, like,
it's very rich, it's quite thick,
but there's a real meaty flavor to that.
Is it the best cottage
pie you've ever had?
No, probably not.
But is it an affordable, filling version
that's fairly true to the original?
I'd have to kind of say yeah.
You do get kind of more filling
as you go into the middle as well.
It wasn't all like that, thankfully.
Yeah, I don't know.
I actually don't think they've
done too bad a job here.
Next up we have this one,
which is the double
chicken fillet sandwich.
Considering the theme of just hefty foods,
this thing is absolutely massive.
Look at it!
Yeah, I think maybe they were supposed to
stack the chicken patties
instead of laying them side by side,
'cause the bun barely covers any of it.
They've also only put one
slice of cheese on it,
so only about 40% of it
is covered in cheese.
I might have to do some quick
tactical rearrangement here.
Oh, there's maybe ...
oh, there's another bit
of cheese on the bottom,
so you get cheese.
Oh, God.
But then it's like, can you eat this?
Because that is also a
logistical nightmare to eat.
I think whichever way you stack this,
it's going to be quite tricky to eat.
But this is the double
chicken fillet sandwich.
There are two chicken
fillets, two slices of cheese,
some lettuce, and some tomato.
Extremely dry.
Very bland.
Like, none of the components
taste of anything, somehow.
It's a bit of a miss.
Again, it's like, it's
big. It would fill you up.
Next up we have the
Korean barbecue beef bake.
So it's like the chicken bake
in that it's kind of a baguette
with some cheese on top filled with meat,
but instead of chicken and bacon,
this one has Korean barbecue beef.
I imagine it's going to be a
similar level of stodginess
to the chicken bake and
also to everything else
that we've eaten today.
The filling on its own
doesn't really taste of much,
which is slightly disappointing.
That's bland. That's disappointing.
I'm still eating it, but it's bland.
It's just, like, nothing
that jumps out to me
as Korean flavors in this.
If you're going to make
something that bland,
I think don't drag Korea through the mud,
just call it a beef bake
and be done with it.
There's one other classic British dish
on the UK Costco menu,
which unfortunately they
forgot to give me today,
and it's jacket potatoes.
There's a note in the
script where Joe says
that he doesn't know
what a jacket potato is,
so I'll do my best to just
explain it to you now.
As the name suggests, it's
basically just a potato
that you keep in your jacket
in case you get hungry.
These can either be boiled or baked.
You'll usually wrap it in some foil
just so that it doesn't
kind of touch anything else
that's in your pocket.
Keep it on you, and then
whenever you get hungry
during the day, you have
a nice snack with you.
As the name suggests,
it's basically a potato that
you keep in your jacket.
[crew laughing]
We also have two exclusive
dessert style options in the UK,
including a caramel fudge sundae
and a coffee caramel frappé.
I didn't get either of them today,
but here's what they look like.
Ahem.
Two cold drinks you can
get here in the US Costco
is the fruit smoothie.
Oh, my God, that's great.
Mm!
Wow, that's really good.
And the cold brew mocha freeze.
Oh, boy, that's melted.
I'm really surprised how
good these cold drinks are.
I mean, their food is good,
but these are really good.
Mm.
Yeah, that's picking me up.
That's picking me up, Yuels!
Let's go!
Ah!
Now I need to calm down a little bit.
And finally in the UK,
we also have mango smoothies on the menu,
although today their machine was broken.
They weren't serving them.
Here's what they look like.
Want to take this moment
to talk about Kirkland,
Costco's signature brand that provides
a wide variety of products for a low cost.
Over the years, the brand has
developed a loyal fan base
among Costco members.
It would be impossible to
feature all the Kirkland
food and beverage items exclusive
to the US not in the UK.
And believe me, I begged management
to let me sample Kirkland's
many alcohol options,
to which they said, "No way."
So here are a few non-alcohol
Kirkland signature
favorite exclusives in the US.
Going to start here: animal crackers.
I mean, come on, UK.
Who doesn't love animal crackers?
Are animal crackers popular
in the United Kingdom?
Oh, my God, let's do the animal review.
I think monkey. Gorilla?
Orangutan?
This looks like a hippo.
We got hippo.
Oh, this is most certainly a koala.
I've seen that guy already.
We're already getting repeats.
Alligator, I think.
Possibly a dragon.
A Brookfield Zoo all
on your fingertips here
in cracker form. Fantastic.
And the US is not playing
with their cheese selection.
So many.
And the one according to the internet
that just everyone is raving about
is, of course, the Parmigiano-Reggiano.
Parmigiano-Reggiano.
1 ½ pounds.
How much do you think a 1 ½-pound
block of Parmigiano-Reggiano costs?
Go.
What do you think?
Actually, it was $16.
Jeez, both of you.
I thought everyone was
going to be like, "$50!"
No, $16. That's still really good.
16 bucks for all this?
I mean, this is going to last, man.
This will last many of your
wine and cheese parties.
And, of course, Costco has a
fantastic selection of wine,
all of which I'm not allowed
to go near, apparently.
According to management.
All right? This video would
be a lot more entertaining
if we were doing the wine review.
Peanut butter, peanut
butter, peanut butter.
When I went to the UK,
I'm not kidding you,
every person I talked to
when they realized I was an American,
which was literally one second
after I opened my mouth,
they all asked me the same thing.
"What is with Americans
and peanut butter?"
Is peanut butter not popular in the UK?
They were like, "You guys put
peanut butter in everything."
We kind of do.
This is really good peanut butter.
Please forgive me, all the
peanut butter heads watching.
Do you want it this liquidy?
'Cause I'm thinking
peanut butter sandwiches,
peanut butter and jelly,
peanut butter and honey,
whatever you're mixing the
peanut butter with, right,
you want some thickness to
it to stay on the bread.
Do we want thin peanut butter?
I don't know. I'm asking you, the viewer.
What is the preferred
viscosity of peanut butter?
I mean, this is creamy,
but I mean, like, cream creamy.
Italian sparkling mineral water
with carbonation added.
If anyone was wondering
just how boring I am,
my favorite sparkling water
is actually the non-flavored.
Right?
Like, LaCroix, my
favorite one's the plain.
That's right, you better "ugh."
I just like the bubbles in the water.
Mm.
Smells Italian.
Oh, yeah, it's really
harsh. This is very good.
Joe: Mm-hmm.
Like, I want that
harshness of the bubbles.
What are you "ewwing" about?
Speaking of Italy, pesto.
So, the basil was imported,
but I don't think this was made in Italy.
Basil. People swear by this stuff.
They swear by it.
Dried mango slices.
This right here, look how many
of these they gave me, man.
This is 2 ½ pounds
of dried organic mango slices.
I am a mango boy.
That's an impressive list of stuff.
We don't have that many
Kirkland exclusives in the UK,
but there is one interesting one I found,
which is this hazelnut spread.
This is just Costco's version of Nutella.
Not "new-tell-uh."
Well, it was interesting
because I was looking at
the ingredients of this,
and the percentages kind
of piqued my interest.
So out of interest, we
googled what the contents
of real Nutella are,
and the ingredients said
that there were 13%
real hazelnuts in there
as well as 7.4% fat-reduced cocoa powder.
So if we compare it to this one,
Leon, how much hazelnut
do you think is in this?
Thirteen percent.
Exactly the same.
Fat-reduced cocoa powder, 7.4%.
So on paper, this has
basically identical ingredients
to real Nutella.
I mean, it smells and
looks a lot like Nutella.
I would struggle to tell
this apart from real Nutella
in a blind taste test, and it is cheaper.
So, hey, next time you're around
and you really, really love Nutella,
you can buy it in bulk here,
and you won't really know.
I also found some products
which weren't Kirkland brand
but did pique my interest.
Marmite.
I found this kind of
catering-size tub of Marmite,
which I could not resist.
I assume this is an exclusive
and not something that
you'd find in the US.
Not 100% sure.
Made Marmite pasta and put
it on Instagram yesterday
and people got upset, so it felt relevant.
And I also found some
American products at Costco
that you wouldn't normally
see on British shelves.
For example, Skippy brand peanut butter.
This isn't bad, but, like,
there's so much oil in here.
You can see it's, like,
running off the top,
and it's kind of made the
whole thing go very liquidy.
According to the ingredients,
this is 10% hydrogenated palm oil,
which might go some way to explaining
why it's so liquidy at room temperature.
These caught my eye while
I was browsing the shelves.
Smucker's Goober?
Neither of those are
real words, first of all.
But this is peanut butter
and grape jelly stripes.
Is this what Americans
are putting in PB&Js?
It claims to be "America's
favorite combination
peanut butter and jelly."
How much competition do
they have in this field?
I'd love to know.
Americans love grape-flavor things,
and it's really not common in
the UK for whatever reason.
I mean, it's quite pretty.
I'd love to see the machine that
puts this into the jar in that pattern.
This is a lot more solid.
I think they've added gelling
agents and stuff to this
to keep it in that uniform shape
with the cool color pattern.
The grape jelly is extremely sweet,
and the peanut butter,
even I think on its own,
is quite sweet compared
to the Skippy as well.
I want to give a disclaimer.
Although this is the exclusive section,
I don't think these are exclusive.
I just know that one awesome thing
about the Costco here in the US,
I don't know if it's in the
UK, Harry can confirm this,
is they have ridiculously
good baked goods.
Costco's in the US is also
famous for having a sheet cake.
Couldn't get it. You gotta
order it ahead of time.
I'm sorry. Let's get a
picture of that on the screen.
With my face on it.
But they have so many
muffins and croissants
and other things.
I heard really good things about
the bakery section of Costco,
so I also had to give that a try.
This goes out to Katya's dad.
Our producer Katya,
apparently her dad really
loves Costco croissants.
I feel like these would
benefit significantly
from being heated up.
It's not bad, as far as
pre-packaged croissants go.
And finally, these cookies.
You get chocolate chip,
double chocolate, and white choc chip.
In the UK, a lot of our
pre-packaged cookies,
for whatever reason,
tend to be really solid,
and you can snap them
rather than chew them.
But this is the much softer
American-style cookie,
which is really good.
Full disclosure, this is the first time
I've ever shopped at a Costco.
And it's not a snob thing.
See, I grew up, my dad
worked for a grocery chain,
and then I move out into the world,
and the thought of having
a case of toilet paper
or bottled water in my
shoebox apartment was crazy.
Also, $60 for a membership?
I mean, I was just scraping by,
so coming up with $60
to go grocery shopping
was madness for me, so.
And then just never went
until now for this video.
And I think Costco's really awesome.
I like it now. Shout-out to Kirkland.
Costco in the UK is a little bit weird
because not just anyone can
actually walk into a Costco.
You have to actually apply
for warehouse membership,
which is different to just
standard online membership.
And to do that, you have to be working
in a certain number of
limited professions.
Some of the professions make sense.
It's things like teachers,
who maybe work in a school
and need to buy supplies,
and some of them are really random.
Things like airline
workers are allowed in.
I think I was technically
allowed in as a journalist,
so this is journalism, if anyone asks.
I believe a year of standard
individual membership
costs around £30, maybe slightly more.
There's different tiers as well.
You can get, like, executive membership,
where you unlock certain perks.
Honestly, I don't really
know why it's set up
exactly this way in the UK.
I guess they want to
kind of have some control
over the foot traffic in the stores.
They don't want everybody
just piling into the store.
I went at 11 a.m. on a Tuesday,
and it was really busy,
and I asked someone on the till,
and they said that that wasn't
even busy by their standards.
I think this is what it's like in the US,
but the shop itself was just
basically an enormous warehouse
with stuff everywhere.
It wasn't organized hugely well.
The aisles weren't particularly labeled.
There were numbers on the aisles,
but didn't say what was in them.
So I just kind of had to snake around
and try and find what I could find.
Things were slightly
cheaper in there than usual,
but I don't even think things
were massively discounted,
particularly the branded stuff
compared to the Kirkland stuff.
So I think you're more just going
because you need to buy things in bulk
and it's slightly more convenient,
rather than because you're
trying to save a lot of money
on your day-to-day groceries.
For me to be able to sign up for this,
they needed to see a pay slip
so they could prove who I was employed by.
Kind of weird.
A whole pizza from a UK
Costco will cost you £9.99,
which at the time of recording was $12.38.
A Costco pizza in the US is $9.95,
or £8.03.
That's a 19.9% price decrease in the US.
The Costco hot dog here in the US
with a 20-ounce soda is $1.50,
the same price it's been since 1985.
How has Costco managed to sell them
for so low for all these years?
In an age where seemingly everything
has been hit by inflation,
the Costco hot dog has become
somewhat of a viral phenomenon.
Their commitment to keeping
the hot-dog combo at $1.50
is so strong that, as the story goes,
when the current CEO
approached the old CEO
about possibly raising the price,
he said, "If you raise the
price of the f---ing hot dog,
I will kill you. Figure it out."
And they did.
Costco would soon switch from selling
Hebrew National hot dogs
in their food courts
to manufacturing their own.
They opened a hot-dog factory
in LA, then in Chicago,
reducing production costs
and keeping the hot dog
at the $1.50 price point today.
It is fair to point out that
our hot dog costs £1.50,
which is more like $1.86.
It does come with two more ounces of soda,
so maybe that's why,
or maybe Costco just likes the aesthetic
of having 1.50 on the sign.
A slice of pepperoni pizza from
a UK Costco is 826 calories,
while a slice of cheese pizza is 751.
The most calorific thing on the menu
is a whole pepperoni pizza.
A whole pepperoni pizza is 4,962 calories,
which is 248% of your daily allowance.
A slice of pepperoni at Costco
in the US is 650 calories.
A slice of cheese roughly the same size
will be 710 calories.
That's 60 calories more.
Hm.
Does that make sense that the cheese
is more calories than the pepperoni?
I gotta.
Mwah.
A UK chicken bake is 911 calories.
An entire US chicken bake is 840 calories.
A UK hot dog is 602 calories.
The hot dog and 20-ounce soda in the US
is 580 to 850 calories
depending on the drink you get.
So least calories would
be, of course, diet Pepsi,
which has zero calories.
If you got a regular Pepsi,
that'd be 250 calories.
And if you wanted to get the
most calories in your drink,
that of course would be 280 extra calories
if you got the Tropicana fruit punch.
Animal crackers.
I mean, come on, UK.
These things ...
This is a twist-off, right?
It's like I'm breaking into a vault.
Come on, just ...